hi yes welcome harika you just made the
draw against jeansai and I know that you
are still analyzing the game in your
head
what happened today because you played a
very nice game you missed the first
opportunity to play Rook C7 let's have a
look at this position here after night
before you could have played Rook C7
yeah maybe but I thought even the more I
played was just fine because okay Rook
C7 also possible of course Bishop A6
maybe I thought like why to give Tempo
so I played Bishop C4
here you will analyze Bishop E6 yeah I
thought like yeah maybe I missed Bishop
B1 or like even Rook p8 is possible here
so basically I didn't want to give this
bishop okay so I decided to go Bishop C4
and I think it's
hit six I didn't I mean I didn't even
think about this more I thought it's
just giving giving away meet the tempo
and after Bishop C4 I'm sure this must
be uh
clearly better
but here night is of course 95 I think I
played everything perfectly and the only
thing I missed was a before night before
Rook C for Rook B6 I forgot Knight D7
Rook C6 exits I just completely missed
in my blindfold calculation and I don't
know
um yeah I think it's just a blindness or
else I think I played a decent game
today and I just uh got a very good
position but then I missed messed up
well we have an unusual situation now of
course only nine players are left in
this tournament did it affect you
no of course not I have seen hampi
closely that she was having health
issues so I'm happy for her that she
managed to get back home and I think
that's the safest way so I think there
are some things Beyond tournament you
would empathize like sympathize the
player more than thinking about your own
tournament so I really didn't think
about it I just wanted to play my best
chess in the remaining games and I think
uh yeah I managed pretty well today but
I guess I just in the blindness maybe
I'm a little tired after like a GP and
playing here I miss something called
completely so what do you think about
your chances to win this tournament
uh I'm not thinking
in that way I'm just trying to see what
I can do in the last three four rounds
actually like uh that's what I thought
to myself
um just to try and do my best because I
understand like there is kind of
uh tiredness and like you know actually
after a long time I'm playing two
tournaments in a row which is a little
difficult these days for me and I'm
doing it so I'm just trying to focus on
trying to play good chess and that's it
and one last question I wanted to ask
you well chess players have visited so
many countries played so many
tournaments is there's a few things on
your bucket list that well maybe are not
chess related but which you dream about
doing
uh
I liked in general to do many things
traveling and I think
skydiving is something I wanted to do
from long time uh yeah so Adventures I
never did so I think I wanted to do it
at some point for sure thank you so much
harika and we will be back after a small
commercial break